Antoine bonsoir alors que vivre en ce
moment la population les populations sur
place Antoine
oui bien cette nouvelle cette annonce de
vladir
[Musique]
quelques cris et quelques secondes après
cette annonce fait par le président
russe mais aussi il faut savoir que
plusieurs dizaines de personnes se
trouvaient sur la place centrale de
Denis il y avait un comment dire un
haut-parleur qui retransmettait en
direct l'intervention du président russe
et à la fin de cette intervention cette
intervention a eu un grand feu
d'artifice long de quelques minutes donc
c'est vraiment la joie et l'espoir ici
pour la population de Denis que cette
population fatiguée après des années de
guerre presque 8 ans de guerre de guerre
larvée mais guerre quand même qui
continue à faire des morts des
bombardements quasiment quotidiens sur
la ligne de contact les gens ont tout
simplement marre et ils espèrent qu'avec
cette décision leur vie changera enfin
Antoine la situation n'a-t-elle pas
empiré ces dernières heures ces derniers
jours les bombardements est-ce qu'ils
ont augmenté
je suis allé dans le quartier de
Petrovski au nord-ouest de donner pour
constater une école qui avait été
touchée par un obus ou encore j'ai pu
voir également l'endroit où avait trouvé
la mort un mineur un homme qui allait ce
matin au petit matin au travail qui a
été fauché par un obus alors qu'il
attendait tout simplement son bus pour
se rendre à son travail donc voici un
petit peu le quotidien en ce moment ces
derniers jours dans les quartiers de
deniès sachant que le porte-parole de la
milice de la république autoproclamée de
données
que la situation était critique en effet
encore dans la soirée il y a eu des
bombardements entendus du côté de Maki
FK qui se trouve à seulement quelques
kilomètres d'ici ou encore à gorlovecam
où nous nous trouvions hier une ville
une ville importante une ville
stratégique qui se trouve qui se trouve
au niveau de
merci beaucoup Antoine pour toutes ces
précisions Antoine Cléon en direct
depuis la région du gambas